[музика]
доброго дня дорогі українці все
українці наші неподільні
від цілісні україни і ті які на
окупованих територіях
відверто кажучи, може бути останній
сау
події більше резонансу вносять саме
ось у ті
окуповані Росії російськими
військами бандитами російськими
нашій території ось там люди живуть ось
тією надією та вірою в Україну і тому
коли тут якісь там я би сказав не
дуже далекі люди мають публічну
майданчик кажуть провокаційні речі
нас чекають там лупити відразу ось
всі наші істоти там ще геть і
шостий рік лагодять опер і треба розумні ти
там уже там там таке поняття акули ти і
без зброї али кожного дня ми там втрачаємо
життя та смерті
сотні людей у ​​в'язницях і ось одним з
таких резонансних висловлювань
з'явилися висловлювання архамі з приводу
того щоб обміняти в цьому
випадку у воду для криму на донбас на ті
на іншу частину окупованої нашої
території я буквально вчора
розмовляв наживо з нашими хлопцями з
крима та
у ньому не цілий список розповіли ось тих
останніх висловлювання офіційних осіб
у владі нової влади які хвилюють
крим і вони і це дуже сильно впливає
ось над на той опір вона не
збільшує вона його пригнічує морально
коли на нормандському форматі президент
говорить про те, що не вискочила години на
ларин криму з ворогом, який вбиває
сьогодні наших там мешканців до розірвав
сім'ї наші
ми не бачимо роками своїх там
родичів близьких дітей онуків
коли ми не можемо ховати своїх батьків і
матерів і ось-ось
можемо бути для цих людей це ось не
вискочила годині а для сотень тисяч наших
громадян там це означає що вони
розцінюють як байдуже 100 ось я таке
прекрасне слово українська і ось
останні ось це ще одна заява щодо
воді тому що п'ять років немає там води
немає там ось цих смачних
дешевих продуктів України тому що 15
14 15 рік вони там кайфували ось ці всі
до лаборанти всі ось ось крим нашисти
та ось ця вся вода яка на
нехтує ось тією боротьбою українців
на ось вогкістю тієї україни цей тих
українців яки
життя не дають за свою свободу за свою
землю за свою державу цій ваті це не
зрозуміти їм пожерти ось там на випити і
і ось існувати тому на тлі
окупації колись якоюсь мірою їх
місце закидали там грошима, а продукти
пости постачалися з України
смачні дешеві до різні асортимент та
коли відбулася блокада звичайно
окупанти були шоковані це що
електрика
перестала надходити і найголовніше
вода і те що ось нікому не вірте те
що зараз нам немає нашої продукції
харчовий я маю
ось продуктів завозиться звідти настільки
неякісна з росії
настільки дороге що донині нашої
сотні тисяч громадян приїжджає до України
та ліки закуповують і продукти
намагаються як хоча б знову
відчути смак ось той ось свіжі та
якісні виготовленої продукції так
це ми щодня з цим стикаємось
тому що ми бачимо в живих наших людей
так ось вода вода це виявився таким ось
серйозним фактором тиск та ще й
непереборною перешкодою для Росії
для як держави як як от імперії зла
до якої а ось силою зброї вирішила
надходити підкорити собі чергову там
колонію на яку вони називають там
крим до них це колонія як вони
хочуть взагалі всю Україну бачити як
колонію Росії так вони не змогли
через шість років
подолати це серйозну проблему
там якщо електрику вони ще пам'ятаєте
китайські подовжувач там простягнули біля
їх весь час є з цим проблеми та а
з водою вони не зможуть дозволити знати
це десь навіть межує я вже сказав у
одному з інтерв'ю що якщо ви пам'ятаєте
декілька тижнів тому
сбу крима по херсону говорила про
відпрацювання
напрями якихось груп, які намагаються
деморалізовані паралізувати
зіграти на проросійських настроях на
на південному сході та й особливо наші рсу ще
не
йдеться про херсонську область і
використовувати ось цей фактор хауса
якихось протестів для того, щоб потім
відкрити шлюзи
ось тут під ось цим ось загалом там ось
такою заварушкою відкрити шлюзи та пустити
воду в крим так от я наприклад сказала
чи не є арахамія одним з
організаторів такої диверсії таких груп
які зараз насправді після
виборів дуже сильно
сепаратисти стали піднімати свої голови
а як а як ще якщо вони бачать
безкарність низки журналістів
пропагандистів у живих та відвертих
українофобів приїжджають і гуляють тут
києву
звичайно безкарність породжує ось
таке ось а смиренність
твоїх твоїх дій проти ненависті до
україні і все, що пов'язано з україни ось
ці
але ми маємо чітко давати відповіді на
такі випади
тому що коли він огульно як лідер
фракції звинувачував у тому, що проплачені
мітинги та подавав у хату заяву щоб
розслідувалися ці факти і так і згодом
теж типу того що
увімкнув задню до скажемо так ні потім
йдуть ще були випади
я не вірю в щирість таких вибачень
і наші відповіді на такі випади
дають альтернативу підходу та й люди
починають вірити вірити що українці не
україну не повалять у реванші за я
слухав виступ на прес-конференції
але новопризначеного голова офісу
президента і де чітко було сказано що
всі ті обіцянки передвиборчі президента
зеленого він буде
це ція знаєш це голова офісу як офіс
президента реалізовувати так ось це
крім там
обіцянок, які стосуються економічного
напрями соціального та там зарплати
вчителям по 4 тисячі доларів там
збільшення там означає соціальних виплат
до зниження тарифів ми вже бачимо
практично вже майже рік скоро буде у
нас навпаки
зворотної тенденції у цих процесів так я
були ж і політичні гасла, які
великі були такою такою технологією
деморалізації суспільство яке п'ять років
мала дуже серйозне зростання
іміджу у світі та поступово суспільства на
навколо цінностей ось об'єднувалася і
формувалось українського суспільства це і
декомунізація це і питання з вагою до
це і питання щодо
децентралізації влади це дуже такі
великі політичні події у тому числі
та здобуття незалежності в релігійному
аспект тому з цього і прийняття змін
до конституції визначальний однозначний
вектор напряму нашої держави до
євроатлантичної інтеграції і ось тут
ми стали чути що світ за всяку ціну
що потрібно припинити війну не визначаючи
ми теж завжди говорили про припинення
війни
але мали конкретну конкретну візію та
abyss
я всім нашим партнерам що росія
напала на нас і ми за свої
за свою країну воюємо віддаємо життя вони ми
не є загарбниками чийсь
території і ось на цих маніпуляцій
що припинити війну не пояснюючи як до
що люди втомилися від війни, тобто ті
які на дивані напевно мали на увазі
лежать цілими днями або по ресторанах
ходять вони втомилися від війни
а ті, які зі зброєю в руках і в
в'язницях сидять і продовжують боротьбу і всі
ті які на материковій Україні
різній формі збільшують успішність силу
нашої країни і в тому числі у розвитку
армії до
було звичайно дуже відчутно що
це ось та демагогія маніпулятивність
щоб збити де фокусувати увагу у
основної частини суспільства від істинних
ворогів України на жаль голова офісу
знову сказав про те, щоб припинити
війну, а ми вже бачимо, що розведення
військ як це називається насправді
відведення наших військ на нашій
території це не забезпечила
припинення вогню мало того у нас є
інформація штабу ос де чітко говориться
що є факти
заняття територій, які ми залишили в
результаті
відступ треба назвати речі своїми
іменами
нами і ось це один фактор ось тих ось
настрій які у суспільстві
висловлюють люди як про таких про
програшних позиціях нашої нової влади
яка сьогодні демонструє і всередині
країни та ворогові ось що найнебезпечніше
ворогові
дата цього до виборів ворог боявся що
зростання сила України є розвал цієї
бандитської путінської влади та розвалом
самої тієї вже прогнилий росії і
тому були всі сили кинуті на нас для
щоб деморалізувати
змінити владу і спробувати змінити і
іншого не важливо якого там президента
але аби не головнокомандувача
полководця як я його називаю і сильною
особи президента порошенка до
жаль це спрацювало але ми нікуди не
поділися і лідер нікуди не пішов він сьогодні
асоціює іншу альтернативну
тієї нової влади частина суспільства та
команду і ми бачимо як він успішно робить
те, що має повинен повинен робити
президент зелінський нова влада на
міжнародних майданчиках і ось це буде
гарантією та низка інших питань я вже
говорив і соціального спрямування
інформаційна політика взагалі зараз
дуже багато скарг з окупованих
територій кодовані канали та
загалом
причому російські канали вони ще
успішніше стали транслювати цю ношу
цю дезу фейки на наші окуповані
території тобто на наші
на наших громадян та прилеглих у тому
числа та й у самому ківі це відчувається
тобто боротьби немає такої я наприклад
вчора в
зробив заяву збу криму від криму
які
[музика]
відповідають за процеси пов'язані з
окупованим кримом по своїй лінії по
безпеки та я їм вказав на факт
що вперше за стільки часу та я ще
не сидів у в'язниці і вже оператори
працюючі в криму телефон мобільні
зв'язки були блоковані на території
україни тобто ти тільки приходив на
так звану нейтральну зону між на
адмінкордон
крима та україни і в тебе оператор
мобільного зв'язку
плюс 7 978 пропадав а вчора я був
свідком того, що на відстані 200
кілометрів від чангара продовжував
працювати
оператор ось цей оператор який
незаконно злочинним чином сприяючи
окупації та незаконної анексії криму
російський оператор працює на нашій
території і такі речі на жаль
дуже зараз останнім часом набирають
великі так і велику таку інерцію це
неприпустимо мовлення на крим і в тому
числа кримсько-татарського каналу і то
є знаєте це є політика України та
до цього треба ставитись саме так потрібно
відпрацьовувати належним чином
необхідною мірою цю політику
чого на жаль ми не бачимо зараз
від представників нової влади
[музика]
я вважаю що кожний що ми зараз
робимо
я маю на увазі силу
політичну силу яка називається
європейська солідарність чому я так
називаю ми
я був у низці поїздок по Україні та люди
саме так висловлюють ставлення до нас
до нашої сили як до якоїсь платформи
які вони можуть навколо які вони
можуть згуртуватися і ось на якій вони
можемо спертися ми
я вважаю що ми вийшли ось із того
стану коли ми в рамках виборів
реєструвалися як партія для участі
зараз до нашої сили ставляться ось як
платформі і я свою думку нашому лідерові
сказав порошенко, бо лідер я
говорю порошенко народний лідер саме
так його сприймають у регіонах коли він
буває у подорожах та коли ми приїжджаємо
представляючи команду лідера порошенка ми
так само відчуваємо від людей такі ж посилання
і
і навіть ті, хто критикував його і ті
які дуже готові згуртуватися вас
навколо нього всі сходяться на одному що в
в порівнянні з новим президентом народним
лідер можна назвати порошенком
ось це і є те, що ми зараз
демонструємо та
у нас якщо ось це ось почуття силою в
тому що ми об'єднавшись з патріотами на
яких нова влада сьогодні лагодить
безпрецедентні дії тиск коли
їх як терпів
на них пишуть заяви та їх за ґрати
намагаються частину кинули а частину намагаються
сховати за ґрати і на людей які
пов'язані з малим середнім бізнесом це
безпрецедентні зміни прийняття
законів які загалом
спрямовані як наші фахівці
говорять на знищення цієї найважливішої
частини суспільства
малий середній бізнес та в області
культури
коли ми бачимо що по відношенню до
українському кіно відверта
відвертий такий ігнор а десь ще й
елемент такого шовінізму проявляється
коли кажуть, що не потрібно фінансувати
українське кіно та й ось це всі ми
не допустимо не допустимо тому що ми
це відчуваємо, що все більше більше
суспільство об'єднується ось навколо такої
платформи в якій
яка демонструє та має досвід
установки державних державних
народних українських таких стовпів
єднання я є вище перерахував і це
вже не сміються як це було у той період
маніпуляції, що там треба було намазати
на хліб то зараз уже дедалі більше
оборотів набирає незалежності
української церкви томас все більше і
більше сили набирає такі процеси як
інтегруватися до європейських інституцій
всім дедалі більше стає
ясним очевидним що ми можемо тільки
разом із нашими партнерами додавити
ворога росію і в тому числі це і нато
стосується що українці не дозволять
повернути відкатати назад і через стільки
років війни зі стільки років стільки
загиблих
тих, хто сидить у в'язницях, не дозволять
ось знехтувати цим і повернутися в
колонію Росії інакше я з боку Росії
не бачу ставлення до нас крима до
українцям кримським татарам до інших
громадянам України
різних національностей ми всі українці
ми маємо гідно як громадяни України
зробити свій внесок у перемогу нашого
перемахнула
[музика]